nice to see you both
in uh in the virtual world uh so i
always like throwing out like some
curveball as my first question
and i'm not sure how much you guys have
thought about this but i'm gonna try it
if you could get the financing for any
project tomorrow
what would you make and why i would make
my dream project which is based on one
of my favorite books
and uh and it's in the vein of you know
movies that i grew up with like hook
goonies um never ending story jumanji
these films that
have these fantastical worlds that
transport you but aren't overproduced
and don't necessarily rely on special
effects to transport you
that's that would be that would be my my
bad i'm very curious what this is
but we'll leave it alone uh what do you
got
uh i i would remake i think either
romancing the stone
there will be blood might have to play
paul dano's character and there will be
blood
okay i was not expecting mean streets
but i like it it's kind of good
i don't get the why i get to talk to you
guys uh this must have been an
interesting film to like see the final
version of because you weren't on set
for half of it
so what was it like actually watching
the film for the first time
i mean it was amazing we were lucky
enough to kind of see the film
throughout different renditions as it
was being edited and
um it definitely transformed a lot
throughout the editing process
and the most exciting thing to me was to
see facing a bond storyline in a way
because
it is 50 percent of the film and 50 of
the film that we weren't exposed to
while we were
portraying our storyline i always love
seeing what the other people have been
doing whilst you're not working i
i i always find that fascinating and and
actually to your point i don't think
that this movie works
without the two stories um
living together i think that they they
help one another and
they bring out moments and and feelings
with each other 100 i love learning the
behind the scenes
of the making of a movie and projects
what do you think people would be
surprised to learn
about the making of this particular film
i don't think people would be surprised
but just how much everyone loves joe
howard
how much everyone fell in love with joe
allen i mean
i don't know if anyone would be
surprised by that he's the true english
gent but
it whole everyone i might i completely
owe my heart to joe allen
yeah joe owen does come in and steal the
hearts of everyone around he's just like
the most genuine
kind present human
and you can't say his name joe you
should have to say full name jerome
that was not the answer i was expecting
but for both of you though i am curious
what was it specifically about this
project that said
i want to do this this is important to
me i wanted to work with augustine
because i think she's just so groovy and
i think she's so creative and i learned
so much from her
and her knowledge of camera and the way
that like she envisioned
envisioned shots was amazing i've never
seen a director go i want the camera to
sweep
up and over and i want it to be a warner
and we have to figure out i have to work
with the cinematographer and the grips
to figure out how we're going to
make the camera feel seamless and feel
like a wanter even though it's being
stitched together
she's genius in that way truly um so
that was very exciting to me and
the big impetus for me wanting to do
this film yeah me too
and then i read the script and um
it really broke my heart and i just
thought i've got to do this you know i
cried at the end
the the tragedy of the the story
as much as the romance i have to stop
there i'm just going to say congrats on
this movie
i hope you guys have a fantastic day uh
and thank you for giving me your time
you stephen you too